good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight so much sadness but
honestly so many great stories right now
texas democrats the ones who fled to
washington you see the freedom fighters
the ones who came on a pilgrimage
there's nothing but a case of miller
light and the coronavirus
well it turns out they've just claimed
several more victims a white house
official and an aide to the speaker of
the house nancy pelosi have tested
positive for covet 19.
apparently they got it from the pilgrims
from texas the moment we'll have an
update on the conditions of the victims
and the scale of the super sweater event
but first tonight
there are a lot of different ways to
sell out to china if you're looking to
do that
if you're an unscrupulous finance mogul
in new york for example you can just
prop up the chinese economy with
billions in investment
wall street has been doing that for
decades if you're an elected official in
washington with a flair for demagoguery
you can do your part by pretending that
the real threat to this country isn't
the rise of chinese power and ambition
no no no no no
the real threat is that dastardly
vladimir putin and his team of secret
agents that his network of macedonian
troll farms
is go on television a lot and say that
maybe people will believe you
the question is what if you don't have
the money
or the rhetorical skills to do either
one of those things but you still want
to help
what if you're a not very bright third
string democratic congressman from the
east bay
how can you do your part for xi jinping
well you could just find a chinese spy
and then have sex with her repeatedly
that's what eric swalwell did now we're
not going to get into the details of
their relationship because this is a
family show and honestly it's pretty
creepy
but we can tell you the spy's name was
fang fang and no we're not making that
up
fang fang unfortunately is not available
to join us on the show tonight she's
fled back to her handlers on the chinese
mainland
ahead of a justice department
investigation but amazingly eric
swalwell is still with us he's still
around
in fact he's been elevated to a seat on
the house intel committee
the perfect reward for the boyfriend of
a chinese spy
in a city obsessed with collusion with
foreign powers eric swalwell
exits his relationship with the chinese
spy and ascends to the intel committee
it does make you wonder swalwell you'll
recall
came from nowhere nine years ago to beat
one of the most powerful and
longest-serving members of congress
fort noy pete stark it took an awful lot
of money to do that but somehow
despite being mediocre and inarticulate
and totally unknown and very young
eric swellow had the money to do that so
where did that money come from
good question after the election the fbi
determined that eric swala had raised
most of that money
illegally a donor called james tong had
supplied the money without complying
with campaign finance laws
to this day we have no idea where most
of that cash came from
swalwell of course pleaded ignorance and
because he's dumb the authorities
apparently believed him how would he
know he was breaking the law the guy's
an idiot that was their reasoning
so well blushed and promised never to do
it again
so from the very first day there have
been real questions about this eric
swalwell character if that is indeed
his real name but you'd never know it
now
such is the magic of resume laundry and
the distorting power of the american
news media
even a [ __ ] with a weakness for sex
with chinese spies
over time begins to look like henry
kissinger if he does enough cable news
hits and that's exactly where eric
swalwell is today
the spy's boy toy is now an elder
statesman that's his personal assessment
of himself
listen it's pro wrestling
to be honest many of my colleagues are
better suited to work at the wwe
uh and i say that about gates because
i've worked with him
on marijuana issues i've worked with him
on other issues
especially really before trumpism took
off
and he turned into a character and he
would
there were times where he would laugh at
himself about how
stupid he had to act you know to keep
you know the
act going i've been working on
marijuana issues says eric's world but
the rest of those guys they're all
clowns says swalwell
adjusting his plastic nose and freight
wig and applying more grease paint
i'm the only serious person in this
building me and fang fang
it is just too funny meanwhile wasn't it
just last week that we got that picture
of eric suoha grinning shirtless on a
camel and cutter
as his faithful servant of color his
cooley looked on adoringly in the
foreground
eric swoe will the great white hunter of
alameda leopards fear him
that particular camel hunt by the way
was paid for by business interests in
the persian gulf
oh so we're starting to sense a theme
here eric swalwell has a problem
with money shocked you shouldn't be like
so many progressives walwell's deepest
desire is to live like a rich guy
out of some movie and that's difficult
on a congressman's salary so corners get
cut here's the latest example of that
campaign finance records obtained by fox
news show that eric swalwell spent
thousands in campaign contributions
that's money he raised to run for
office money he has prohibited by
federal law from spending on himself
he spent that money on expenses that
seemed suspiciously like
personal luxuries those would include
limo rides
booze deliveries high-end steak houses
and some of those expenditures appear
very clearly to be
for personal use and again that's
illegal
for example one order at the alcohol
delivery service drizzly
was for under 10 was that a campaign
event no
the man just wanted his tequila sunrise
and he wanted it now
and so the donors paid for it most
interestingly on the disclosure form
more than twenty thousand dollars of
eric swellow's campaign expenditures
went to the ritz-carlton hotel
in half moon bay california now weirdly
or maybe not so weirdly
eric swalwell's wife is an executive at
that very hotel
so clever members of congress the honest
ones don't do things like that and when
they do things like that they tend to
get in very deep trouble
in fact it was just two years ago that
congressman duncan hunter of san diego
same state different party
pleaded guilty in federal court to
stealing hundreds
of thousands of dollars in campaign
funds that he and his wife use for
personal expenses he went to jail for 11
months
then in 2013 you'll also recall
congressman jesse jackson jr and his
wife both democrats
went to prison for the same thing now
we're not saying eric swellow should be
charged with sleeping with a chinese spy
or for misusing campaign funds but we do
know that under the standards that eric
swallow himself has laid out
we're going to need an immediate federal
investigation
possibly a special counsel
the american people deserve to know what
the russians have exactly on donald
trump
whether it was witting or unwitting the
end result is just as destructive
because the president has drawn us
close to a foreign adversary who is not
our friend
[Laughter]
oh eric swallow saying someone else drew
close to a foreign adversary was not our
friend
really how close eric swoe well
[Laughter]
so what's going on with eric swallow and
why don't we deserve to know what a
sitting member of the house intelligence
committee is doing with russian spies
with his campaign contributions and on
that now famous camel in
cutter and what does his cooley think of
this does he really adore eric swalwell
as he pretended to in the picture
probably not let's subpoena him hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else